[Music]  last year we create an exciting new  legal drama and it stirred our bands  trombone lair la Bamba and it was called  la Bamba legal yeah it was great it was  great we only made one of them but it  was so good we decided not to make any  more in this time around la Bamba plays  a highly trained CIA operative so take a  look at this clip from la Bamba lethal  I'm in position I have my eyes on the  kill zone do you have the package  affirmative  our Ozzy's Caravan is 1,000 meters out  so you'll have to move quickly no sweat  I can assemble an mi-28 1s in my suit  Roger  [Music]  [Music]  that's what I was thinking there might  be a different hey this is sound  [Music]  the talking has left the kill zone  agent lebombo do you have let shop night  next on la Bamba Lisa  the shot the shot is there but I don't  have the I'm not really  [Applause]  I think that's another project you only  see one of them probably they'll be one  and that's it